um anyway I watched the Irishmen and
people were talking about how fantastic
it is and yeah I mean Scorsese really
could make a [ __ ] movie huh that's
what you realize when you watch that
movie you'd be like aw course is it
could really make a [ __ ] movie huh
this guy just killed it like the [ __ ]
sequences and [ __ ] the sequences and the
scenes the scenes just standing alone
some of these seams just went like Al
Pacino and Robert De Niro talking and
you're like goddamn well now but you
know it's just like oh yeah you know
he's like oh that's the [ __ ] scenes
and then Pesci is just like yeah puddin
you're just oh yeah that's the scene in
the Irishman that's my favorite scene in
the Irishman but dude the [ __ ] [ __ ]
is so and then the other guy the British
dude that's in it that plays the [ __ ]
the other guy the guy from what's that
[ __ ] house of cards but in that 1400s
the HBO show matt says it's his favorite
show ever Boardwalk Empire house of
cards in the fourteen hundreds whatever
the [ __ ] that movie show us that's what
I call that show and and he's just like
and I'm like this guy's British how's it
gonna pull off a [ __ ] mobster and he
just comes in he's like you just don't
understand and on my god damn it British
guys British actors could [ __ ] play a
white British guy could play an Asian
and just be Asian and and you'd be like
no I won't make up
hold on they'd make up I've got acting
I've got acting in my corner or donate
my cup of God acting in my corner and
he'd be like whoa okay and he would come
on this on the set he would just be like
Gordon Jupiter will do a [ __ ] on ya oh
god no you got nuts order and they'd be
like Jesus Christ
maybe I cut maybe like oh that was a
good one I can go another Tiger
something like that okay let's get
touch-ups hold on need a touch-up I've
got Achtung in me corner and action cut
always craft service I need I need some
almonds I need some almonds and some
peanut butter anywhere watch the [ __ ]
Irishman
and you know the way it starts is a
Scorsese all right it's like you know
when we started like one of those
[ __ ] things you know you remember
Goodfellas when he was just like as far
back as I can remember I always wanted
to be a gangster man my lamb you know
and whatever the [ __ ] it was and then in
this one it's just like hey you know
when we first started and it just that's
how I [ __ ] DeNiro and then but uh
yeah I watched it and broke my buddy
Sebastian is in it okay this abashed
Maniscalco bro i knew he was in it okay
but when you see him in it you're like
oh dude my friends in a [ __ ] nut
Martin Scorsese movie and he's [ __ ]
dude got sunglasses and he's just
walking around
dude he's acting with Ben Nero oh man
dude it's like a trip he's acting
without Pacino and he's doing his
sebastian [ __ ] al pacino's like [ __ ]
oh yeah
and Sebastian's like what it's [ __ ]
awesome dude anyway I was watching the
Irishman and I was thinking about how
Anna Paquin was in it and I was like man
she's kind of killing it in my head I
was like man she's killing it and she
doesn't even really have lines you know
and I was like that's just to goes to
show you is you don't need lines to be a
good actor you know I'm talking about
and
and I was looking at Twitter I think is
this dude it's yeah good okay I was
looking at Twitter and people were like
upset that Anna Paquin through this [ __ ]
kills me if the people that said Anna
Pat Anna Paquin only had seven lines in
the irishman and them and and people
were like oh it's sexist and it's like
so hilarious first of all because just
make the [ __ ] move you want your
Martin [ __ ] Scorsese well what do you
think martin scorsees gonna make a movie
about he's gonna make a movie about some
[ __ ] old gangsters that's so he's
gonna make a movie about okay so people
are like oh Anna Paquin was in and you
only had seven lines first of all she
auditioned for the part you don't get
Hollywood okay see ya the gunk all right
now also the movie is literally about
one of the main parts of the movie is
about a dad and a daughter that don't
have a good relationship and don't speak
to each other so how the [ __ ] are you
going to give her more lines when that's
what the movies about people are so
[ __ ] I wrote people mad that Anna
Paquin only had seven lines in the
irishman the movies about how De Niro
wasn't a good dad and didn't talk with
his daughter also had a pack was still
killed it and I was thinking about how
Anna Paquin was killing it her
performance was true acting just not
with the lines dude and you know that's
hard to do - it's so late like there's
not enough [ __ ] everything they
reboot is with women anyway do it